- For this video, my mom is
dressing me for a whole week.
We did a similar thing two years ago,
where she chose one outfit for me.
You like it?
I feel super hot right now.
I can't wait to slip into shorts.
I'm not used to wearing sweats,
and like, this hoodie, all day long.
Thick cotton material.
People had opinions all over the place,
definitely feel a lot younger, cooler ...
- Like a ... artsy cool side
that I never dress myself in.
What is this?
- I am not used to expressing
myself in such loud colors,
kind of like a fun side of
me that my mom pulled out.
A childhood side of me
that I've not gotten in
touch with in a while.
I'm pleasantly surprised.
I would probably wear this again.
- What the semi-turtleneck is this?
I've never worn this
color ever in my life.
I'm normally very particular
with the type of hat
that I wear, I usually have
a specific shape that I like,
and this is not it.
It makes my head too flat.
Wait til you see this text.
Also looks like prescription.
I'm reading it by word,
because I'm reading it--
- [Lien] I-den-tee-fee.
- What is this?
- In-te-freh.
- What? In Asia, you know how those memes,
it'll say like, cuss words
with flowers around it,
it just doesn't matter.
It's just words and font.
Obviously, the words on here don't matter.
- I really like it a lot.
- [Kane] Uh huh. Yeah.
- I'm not mad about it. Your
mom did a really good job.
This color on you is everything, like--
- Yeah?
- You need to wear this color more often.
- I'm starting to think that my mom
might be more fashionable than I am,
because some of the Instagram
photos that I posted
have three times the likes that
my normal photos would get.
- I'm going to a friend's
birthday party today.
This is 100% something my dad would wear.
This pattern, this polka dot pattern.
I've actually never had
a real watch before.
I've had an Apple watch, but like,
I've never actually had a legit watch.
I look like a dad.
This pair of shoes,
pretty simple and clean.
Good job. What do you think, mom?
- Oh! So handsome boy.
Yeah, so I hug you.
- Okay. What do you think about the watch?
- I'm actually surprised that
your mom is quite stylish.
- It's very hip. It's very shocking.
- I was actually very surprised.
Literally none of the clothes she chose,
I would've chosen for me
now, but after wearing it,
there were definitely items
that I would wear again.
- Update! It's been a few weeks
since I filmed with my mom.
What's wild is that I had no
idea this whole experience
would impact my style so much.
Literally, if you look at my Instagram,
I have a completely new look,
my wardrobe is completely different.
I had no idea that in my 20s,
my mother would refresh my wardrobe.
What?
Just started getting into watches,
I've started wearing
different types of hats,
just more color in general.
Jumping over that hurdle
about like, this is not me,
I look awkward in it.
The fact that I did it,
and things were okay,
now I feel a little bit more daring.
This video has probably
impacted my style the most,
out of all the videos that I've done.
So thank you, mom!
Let me know which one
is your favorite outfit
which one should I
continue wearing more of,
and would you let your
mom dress you for a week?
(laughter)
(house music)